l'être humain est un désir instinctif de
vie privée qui existe depuis toujours
si je vous disais que donc nos maisons
n'ont pas toujours eu des murs pour
didier les pièces et donne un peu
d'intimité aux occupants
la pratique de placer une lettre dans
une enveloppe avant de la mettre à la
poste est apparu quelques centaines
d'années on retrace dans nos archives
des poursuites devant les tribunaux pour
avoir écouter aux portes pour avoir
ouvert des lettres personnelles
bref la vie privée n'a rien de nouveau
alors comment se fait-il que 36
candidats liés à la vie privée rapporté
dans nos médias au cours des dernières
années
peut-on protéger la vie privée avec des
lois c'est une page extrêmement complexe
et c'est une tâche difficile parce que
ce qu'on tente de protéger la vie privée
changent constamment et très rapidement
donc c'est comme aller à la chasse et
tenter d'attraper la vie privée et
tenter d'attraper un animal qui kiko
trop vite qui soudainement se met à
voler c'est comme viser une cible qui
est toujours en mouvement
notre besoin de vie privée s'est
amplifiée au cours des 150 dernières
années avec la révolution industrielle
moderne il est devenu plus difficile
d'échapper aux regards indiscrets de ses
voisins la publicité commerciale est
devenue omniprésente dans nos vies et
comme il fallait s'y attendre avec
l'arrivée des nouvelles technologies
notre besoin de vie privée s'est
accentuée pour arriver à protéger la vie
privée avec des lois il faut bien
arriver à définir ce qu'on tente de
protéger
on a défini la vie privée trois fois au
cours des 150 dernières années donc la
première fois c'était vers la fin du 19e
siècle et à cette époque là c'était la
photographie instantanée qui inquiétait
c'était nouveau de pouvoir prendre des
photos alors que plusieurs célébrités
qui s'inquiétait de se faire prendre en
photo dans un contexte intime peut-être
dans leur cour arrière
et puis de se retrouver en première page
la presse populaire
on a donc défini la vie privée à cette
époque là comme étant le droit de vivre
en paix sans être dérangé puis vers la
fin des années 40 suite à la deuxième
guerre mondiale
l'inquiétude était en fait les études
était de s'assurer que les atrocités de
la guerre ne se répète pas en l'état qui
utilisent des renseignements personnels
comme l'affiliation politique la race la
religion l'orientation sexuelle pour
discriminer certains citoyens voire
éliminer des portions entières de sa
population
on a donc défini la vie privée à cette
époque là comme étant le droit d'être
protégé contre des ingérences dans sa
vie familiale son domicile sa
correspondance puis vers la fin des
années 60 début des années 70 avec
l'arrivée de l'ordinateur
l'inquiétude était qu il serait beaucoup
plus facile d'échanger des
renseignements par l'entremise de base
de données automatisés donc l'inquiétude
c'était que des renseignements
personnels à lettres échangées pu
utiliser pour prendre certaines
décisions exemple j'arrive à la banque
je tente d'obtenir un prêt on me refuse
le prêt je demande pourquoi on dit ah je
me base sur certains renseignements que
j'ai obtenue à votre sujet et là arrive
les questions quels renseignements êtes
vous certain que ce sont mes
renseignements personnels qui vous les a
transmises êtes vous certain que ce sont
des renseignements qui sont à jour on a
donc défini à cette époque la vie privée
comme étant le droit d'un individu de
garder le contrôle sur ses
renseignements personnels et c'était là
la dernière fois qu'on a défini la vie
privée donc malgré toutes les avancées
technologiques des 50 dernières années
on se retrouve avec une des lois qui
sont basées sur une définition la vie
privée établie au début des années 70
est-ce que c'est réaliste de s'attendre
à ce que chaque citoyen chaque
consommateur soit en mesure de garder le
contrôle sur ses renseignements
personnels s'impliquerait quoi
s'impliquerait qui lisent la politique
de confidentialité de chaque entreprise
avant d'interagir avec l est qui
la comprennent ans et politiques lauzon
de plus en plus longues de plus en plus
complexes donc peut-être que le temps
est venu de revoir nos lois revoir notre
définition de vie privée pour s'assurer
que nos lois restent efficaces
lorsqu'on pense à la vie privée il ya
toujours un aspect instinctif qui est
présent on sait ce qui est acceptable ou
non en rencontrant dans un ascenseur
j'irai pas me coller aux autres
individus je me mette debout face à la
porte je vais pas avoir le visage collé
con celui d'une autre personne
y a pas de loi qui me dicte comment agir
dans un ascenseur s'est fait du tiff
on ne peut pas protéger la vie privée
avec des lois sans tenir compte de la
règle de conduite de la société en
commun est ce que nous tous
agissons dans certaines situations la
règle de conduite de la société on
l'appelle la norme sociale de nos jours
n'importe qui peut ruiner la vie et la
réputation d'une autre personne avec un
simple clic donc un fléau au cours des
dernières années qu'on appelle la
pornographie vengeresse donc c'est une
pratique qui consiste à partager des
vidéos ou des photos de la thur intime
sans le consentement l'individu la
première loi qui est apparue aux états
unis pour adresser ce fléau la visée la
situation où la photo ou la vidéo intime
de l'individu était prise sans son
consentement ou à son insu et là on a
rapidement réalisé que dans la grande
majorité des cas c'est la victime qui
elle même se prend en photo et la
partage donc l'infraction tel pour la
berri ji ne s'appliquait presque jamais
leur a fallu tenir compte de la norme
sociale la règle de conduite des
victimes pour s'assurer de bien attraper
la situation qu'on souhaite protéger la
norme sociale est en constante évolution
et prend un certain temps pourrait bien
établie à titre d'exemple lorsque je
vais au jam
j'entre dans les vestiaires je sais que
c'est inapproprié de sortir mon
téléphone cellulaire
là où des gens se changent mais c'était
peut-être pas le cas il ya quinze ans il
ya vingt ans à une époque où nos
téléphones cellulaires n'avait pas de
caméra un donc vous remarquerez même
certain jim mettre des affiches dans les
vestiaires téléphones cellulaires
interdit en la norme sociale est en
train de s'ajuster tranquillement à la
situation
on n'aurait peut-être pas besoin de loi
pour adresser ces situations-là la norme
sociale vont évoluer se mettre en place
le défi de nos jours c'est qu'il y à des
avancées technologiques des nouvelles
technologies des pratiques d'affaires
qui arrive extrêmement rapidement sur le
marché donc dans bien des cas ces
technologies arrivent là est la norme
sociale n'est pas en place où elle n'est
pas bien établies
un autre point qui est très intéressant
c'est que cette norme sociale est en
constante évolution donc il peut même
arriver que nous à ces deux sociétés ont
changé d'idée par rapport à certaines
technologies ans lorsque l'afficheur
téléphonique est apparu vers la fin des
années 80 plusieurs trouvé que le fait
d'afficher le nom et le numéro de
téléphone la personne qui appelait
portait atteinte à sa vie privée
à un point tel que certains étant
américains l'avaient interdit
aujourd'hui comme plusieurs lorsque je
sois un appel si je ne connais pas ni le
nom ni le numéro de téléphone qui
m'appelle dans bien des cas je refuse de
répondre
donc c'est comme si une technologie qu'à
une certaine époque était considérée
comme portant atteinte à la vie privée
la personne qui appelle est maintenant
considérée comme une technologie qui
protège la vie privée de la personne qui
reçoit l'appel
un dernier point c'est que non seulement
c'est difficile de protéger la vie
privée avec des lois en plus de ça
lorsqu'on rédige nos lois il faut tenir
compte de d'autres droits et intérêts
qui pourraient s'appliquer
donc si je reprends l'analogie de la
chasse on sait la vie privée on veut
attraper la vie privée mieux beaucoup de
cibles auto qu'on ne veut pas attraper
ses cibles là c'est quoi
d'autres droits d'autres intérêts
quelques exemples un gouvernement a
nécessairement besoin de collecter des
renseignements personnels de ses
citoyens
et dans certains cas de départ de
partager pour bien gouverner
on l'a vu avec la coved récemment un
gouvernement tout intérêt lorsqu'un
citoyen dispositif de savoir qui cette
personne-là au côtoyé durant sa période
de contagiosité pour limiter la
propagation du virus donc à trop
protéger la vie privée
le gouvernement se retrouverait à ne pas
protéger la santé publique
au cours des dernières années il ya en
europe un nouveau droit qu'on appelle le
droit à l'oubli
donc c'est un droit qui me permettrait
at-il d'individus de faire retirer
certaines publications publié sur
l'internet qui me critiquent ou qui me
dérange donc soif à retirer l'accès ou
rendre l'accès plus plus difficile
donc c'est un droit qui protège ma vie
privée mais si je l'exercent je porte
nécessairement atteinte à la liberté
d'expression de l'otan à l'article en
jetant sur son article et je vous
empêche tous de consulter cet article là
donc je porte atteinte à votre droit
d'accéder à l'information
si j'ai déjà été accusé de fraude et que
j'ai l'intention de travailler en
politique vous avez tout intérêt à
consulter cet article là surtout si
c'est vrai finalement les entreprises
sont très actives dans le domaine de la
recherche du développement d'ailleurs on
l'a vu plusieurs d'entre elles ont ont
sorti des vaccins contre lacko vide
si on les empêche de collecter et
d'utiliser des renseignements personnels
à des fins de recherche qu'on rend cet
axe-là trop difficile on pourrait se
trouver à manquer des belles
opportunités en matière d'innovation
bref tout ça pour dire que lorsqu'on
prépare nos lois en matière de vie
privée
il faut tenter d'arriver au parfait
équilibre entre la protection de la vie
privée d'un côté et puis tous les autres
droits ou intérêts qui peuvent également
être impactés par nos lois sécurité
nationale
innovation liberté d'expression santé
publique et autres donc en résumé si on
arrive à trouver une bonne définition de
la vie privée si on tient compte
la norme sociale et si on arrive à bien
tenir compte d'autres droits et intérêts
qui pourraient s'appliquer
est ce qu on pourrait arriver à avoir
des belles lois en matière de vie privée
qui soit efficace
c'est une tâche complexe
ce n'est pas impossible mais
malheureusement on n'arrivera jamais à
faire plaisir à tout le monde
premièrement il des différences
culturelles donc en europe c'est une
juridiction où la vie privée c'est un
droit fondamental
c'est un droit très précieux on est très
motivé à le protéger
en chine la situation est différente
donc au cours des dernières années il ya
certaines provinces qui ont mis en place
un système de notation des citoyens donc
on regarde
est ce que le citoyen des antécédents
criminels
est-ce que ils ont déjà fait faillite
comment il agit sur les médias sociaux
et puis on leur assigne une note et
cette note là peut être utilisé pour
prendre des décisions à leur égard par
exemple ça pourrait être décidé s'ils
sont éligibles à certains avantages
sociaux
ce genre de système là serait impensable
au canada et dans la plupart des pays
démocratiques
tout ça pour dire que arrive un
consensus mondial sera toujours
extrêmement difficile même si ce serait
l'idéal en contenu que de plus en plus
des changes nous renseignements
personnels qui vont au delà nos
frontières
est ce que la vie privée est importante
absolument et pour plusieurs raisons la
vie privée nous permet de rester nous
mêmes de se développer
elle nous permet de protéger notre
réputation
elle nous permet d'avoir des relations
saines avec nos amis avec notre famille
bref la vie privée nous offre une
certaine liberté et même dans certains
cas une protection physique ou même
émotionnel les lois en matière de vie
privée sont importantes parce que c'est
irréaliste de se fier à tout le monde
qu'ils pourraient gérer nos
renseignements personnels donc aux
entreprises aux gouvernements aux eaux
individus pour toujours prendre les
bonnes décisions est arrivé à protéger
notre vie privée tout en tenant compte
des autres droits ou intérêts qui
peuvent s'appliquer
une chose est certaine nos lois en
matière de vie privée ne seront jamais
parfaites on s'est trompé dans le passé
on va se tromper dans l'avenir
donc on n'a pas fini d'entendre des
scandales liés à la vie privée un point
positif la société ares son mot à dire
d'où l'importance pour nous tous d'avoir
une vision claire des enjeux de vie
privée ainsi nous qui allons devoir
décider ce qui est acceptable ou non on
va devoir faire des choix en tenant
compte des avantages que nous procure
certaines technologies et aussi des
inconvénients sont considère que ces
technologies sont trop intrusive et ces
choix là vont avoir une importance
capitale tant sur notre quotidien que
sur l'évolution de notre espèce
merci
[Applaudissements]